hi there Steve Kaufman this is just a
quick video to announce that once again
I'm traveling my wife and I are leaving
kinetics Carmen and I are leaving on the
eighteenth of December this Wednesday
we're flying to Vienna we're going to be
in Vienna from the 19th leaving in the
morning of the 23rd so we'll be there
essentially the 20th the 21st and 22nd
from Vienna we're going to Bratislava
where we pick up a rented car my son his
family from London are joining us and we
are heading to the tatra mountains will
be staying near poprad in Slovakia from
the 20 the evening I guess of the 23rd
until the evening of the 30th then we're
going to all emotes in Moravia and the
Czech Republic two nights in all modes
over New Year's then tues normal we're
gonna hopefully drink some Moravian wine
one more night in Bratislava on the
second where we hand in our rented car
and then we're taking a train up to
Prague will be in Prague January third
to january six so if any of you are in
vienna bratislava poprad all emotes is
no mo no mo whatever it is prague let me
know and perhaps we can meet up so i'm
hoping to meet up with some of you on my
next visit to europe and we can speak
various languages bye for now